congratulations to our next guest
calling in right now his is a book on
Durant KD Kevin Durant's relentless
pursuit to be the greatest is being
released today from the Athletic Bay
Area columnist Marcus Thompson how are
you Marcus I'm a little excited today
yeah I'm right I mean it's it's a big
game tonight Marcus you know and I kind
of love the fact that Damon is coming
home to the spot where he grew up he
grew up in Oracle he told a great story
about the old mascot and his memories of
going back there this is a fun matchup
I think we're getting tonight oh man I'm
so into this game coming home you know
I'm from Oakland I grew up very close to
where they live but if I'm part so I
know like as what who's from here like I
feel like this is so fitting like this
beats the world to us from Oakland that
when they turn out the lights at Oracle
like Damian Lillard will get to the side
as they have all the roots before it
goes like that's so cool to me like it's
so epic that someone who grew up here
and you know basketballs huge here
especially Haven a high school so we've
watched all these stars over the years
like make their name we followed their
careers and and it's fitting that day
was the last one from Oakland to play at
Oracle like that's just so cool to be
well I mean also he could turn the
lights on in the place I mean he and the
Blazers have that opportunity certainly
if Durant is out for a considerable
amount of time let's get to that part
what can you tell me about Durant's
availability in this series Marcus I
don't think we see him before the series
shifts to Portland I don't think he
plays the first two games Steve Kerr
said he hasn't even taken the court yet
like he has he's not shooting he's not
ready his cast is still giving him pain
so I don't know I don't see it I may be
in Portland they can they can uh kind of
like you know break him in so to speak
like see how it goes I think he doesn't
play until a loss happens for the
Warriors at Portland speaks one it turns
out the clock but if they don't lose
then I don't think he comes back because
they still need to get him on the
court to practice yes touch the court
yet well in terms of that two about
needing him right and you're pointing
about how if the the Blazers draw blood
sooner then expected
even without Durant obviously the way
that the pre Durant Warriors showed up
to close out the Rockets that the idea
that we're we're seeing and in the
conversation throughout the nation is
that the Warriors don't need Durant and
this is this indication of him getting
ready to leave to get his own situation
let's dive into that one first and
foremost in your latest column about
that well from a couple days ago that I
was reading about the Warriors speaks so
highly of Durant give us a glimpse into
how Durant has woven himself into the
fabric of this team Marcus you know
really displeased playoffs there's been
like an uptick really the last month of
the season where it's almost like they
all just decided to flip a switch and be
the most together team they could be and
it hasn't been that way it's been
Rockies and up and down like that the
effort has waned but the connectivity is
way and obviously they had their blow-up
it over between Durant's reruns
like they've had a lot of issues but
then they're like March suddenly like
they were all in and now there's this
harmonious locker room it was it was
amazing to me like everyone was talking
about how low this is the throwback
right these are the old warriors they
don't need to rent and they were in a
locker room said oh yeah we'd eat up
we had the women's game so we should get
our guy back so it's it's really it's
been unique I don't think this has bit
it hasn't been like this is maybe year
one that they're all kind of like in
love with each other it's like place for
each other yesterday in the bill session
Katie was the most vocal one like he was
in there talking into it they're into
him he's into them it's it's probably
not a good it's probably a good size for
people who are like wanting to go to New
York but and as been a book they're like
look if this is our last run let's make
it a deal once you kind of get that set
for them so then can you Marcus tops
into the athletic
here on the Rich Eisen show can can you
pinpoint or give us anything from behind
this
- when this harmonious sness arrived and
why and how it could last regardless if
Durant doesn't somehow for whatever
reason returned to play return to action
so I think it began there was a middle
of March the Warriors lost to Dallas I
don't remember the exact date but they
got blown out by Dallas at home and it
was kind of a low point because they
were supposed to be like all right now
it's playoffs in here let's turn it up
there supposedly flipping the switch to
getting ready to go and Steph was out
and they got blown out in Dallas and
Durant went not for 25 and like the next
three games after that he stopped shoot
he was really becoming like a floor
general and he was running point he's
passing the ball you know for these
three years the conversation has been
about like gets rid of the ISO and
getting him into like the warrior style
of basketball movement it flow so during
a stretch he became like the point guard
for it like Steph was off the ball play
was off the ball and it was a lot of KD
being a facilitator and I think he was
kind of saying all right listen let's go
all in this way then let's just do this
and then they faced the Clippers and
they needed him to kind of carry the
show and I think you started hearing
people saying is the best player in the
world he's the best player in the world
when he's dropping 50 at night it feels
like it's like during that that
march/april they all kind of decided
like hey this dude is really bought he's
really buying it he's really like
promoting a style of basketball we play
and look at what he's doing like even
Steph Curry's call it but there's
clarity so they all have kind of
anointed him the transition of power so
to speak from Step two to Kevin Durant
it just feels like it was organic but I
remember when it began in March and it's
interesting I think they're ready to say
this this is our future I think this
might even be their pitch right like
look this is how it's gonna be if you
stay inside like the subliminal pitch it
we will be great this you're the band
we're here supporting you like we got we
got players like all of us together and
great even if you're the top dog it's
just fine I
that's how they've been it it's gonna be
a great sales pitch for what it's not
fair to make a decision and one more on
this subject before we turn to the
series itself again Marcus Thompson of
the athletic and again your your new
book on Durant
KD Kevin Durant's relentless pursuit to
the be the greatest being released today
so knowing Kevin as you do how do you
think he views this do you think he
views it like saying hey the guys I get
along with them they love me they
respect me they know they need me but
hey I don't need to be in a situation
where it all falls apart if I leave I'm
glad to be in a spot where I can still
win a title potentially even if my right
calf does give way at the most
inopportune time or the ping pong balls
bounce tonight Zion winds up in the
hands of the Knicks and he realizes that
there's a legacy building opportunity
there that's even better than staying
put and starting a new regime and a
gorgeous spot Michael Wilbon told us
about this new story no that's amazing
where do you think he leans knowing him
as you do it's a tough call because
Kevin Durant is a very multi-faceted
dude like there's a part of him that
just loves the essence of basketball the
purity of it and the team element and
the camaraderie like he I mean he is
sappy about that stuff he loves it like
he's a purist in that sense that's one
of the reasons he came to the lawyers so
this is kind of that euphoria now like
that their experience is like
everybody's playing like a team
everybody's like unselfish everybody's
playing their role they like each other
as Steph calls it they're they're vibing
right now they got a really good vibe
like he loves that stuff but then
there's also the Kevin Durant who like
feels like everybody needs to recognize
how good he is and he's not stopping
until we all say uncle right so if the
question becomes which wins out right
which is the most important thing to him
that's the thing I think we don't know
yet we don't know of all these things
that matter to him which is the most
important and which one decides and
maybe this time he came to the Warriors
that was for the basketball
purity part a baby this decision is it
that like we don't know but he
definitely has these elements to him
where you could say yeah I can see they
want to do that
yeah Cassini was yeah and right now he's
a little bit I mean he's not playing but
he's a little bit and basketball heaven
because I'm a ever since Patrick
Beverley was fully you know said it
balance I say he said I'm Kevin Durant
y'all know who I am right like it's been
it's been six gear and they've been in
like basketball their father
yeah I'm nice right when he says I'm
nice when he's just like yeah he's
dropped he's dropping 50 I mean hey look
III think he's the most valuable player
in the league and and I think he'd be
nuts to leave a situation like this and
I know that you know these guys I've
been around each other for a while and
like many marriages it takes it takes a
village to keep it moving forward but
that's for another day let's talk about
tonight then and and the opportunity in
front of Oakland native Dean Lillard and
this team with McCollum playing flawless
basketball to help close out the Nuggets
down 3-2 what what do you think of the
Blazers opportunity here to actually
shock the world and get this done I
think it starts from tonight I think
Game one is their shot and look the
worries all year has been known to let
their hair down right put their feet up
it's still a little bit and coming off
that emotional series they have with the
Rockets like this is a trap game for
them like this is one of those games
where they happy they might have a leg
they might not have the energy and
Portland can pounce only problem is poor
they might be tired too right they just
came off their all seven-game series I
do think in the air and you know you
know these series are all about like
talent like the best team wins the
Warriors just have more talent and the
worst part for Portland is that their
strength is also the warrior strength
and the warrior strength is better like
they got a backcourt that's incredible
and the words of that court is also
incredible with three championships so
they're gonna be in a tough spot but if
you could shoot like they can if you can
make threes like they can you can run
you they have a bunch of chance and but
they got to get that
they got a LAN tonight I think if they
lose Game one and let the words get
their bearings and come back for Game
two and now you start talking about
whether Durant come back because they
still have that ace in the hole
that's that's a tough one
it's a tough role for Portland in this
situation especially without their kids
because the big man is really what
causes the Warriors problem right and is
Durant gonna be there tonight
you think he's there I think he will be
there he might not be all the [ __ ] but
Oh usually in the back he's usually kind
of wait no I know that but I just wanted
you know obviously him him getting out
there and like physically being there
and on the bench might would be make for
an interesting visual that I'm trying to
put my mind's eye on like he loves it he
loves it like the whole Rana Rana we're
just like you love that book and then
one last thing for you Marcus since
again you mentioned that you are from
the Auckland area
oh just give voice to what it's like
right now you know the Raiders are
leaving they're going to Vegas we're
seeing that thing going up the Warriors
are going across the bay there will
still be in the area but they're not
going to be in Oakland anymore what's
going through the minds of the Oakland
sports fan with Dane coming home and the
or and Oracle maybe getting closed out
in this round if not then the next I
think there's there's this like clinging
to the native athlete you know I think I
think we're all we all are like feeling
a little bit jilted and a little bit
like you know disrespect it and we
already have that chip on our shoulder
anyway right but like being in the
shadow of a San Francisco kind of
created [ __ ] for you so I do feel like
the fact that the Warriors shows their
Cisco the fact that the Raiders are
running along Vegas
it makes us like we we're in our cinemas
for sure okay put that that's where we
celebrate you know the players who are
from here and that's why dame has has
really kind of stepped forward as the
face of the city and Marshawn Lynch like
people are begging able to come back and
you know play one more year even though
the rumor is is retired but those
players who come from this soil are
meaning a lot more
knowing that the landscape is about to
change forever
so we are all a little like I well at
least I still got day right at least you
still got Marcus Peters and those those
guys are about to become like local
celebrities like they've ever were just
because the teams are leaving and the
landscape is changing and that's in
addition to the city changing right when
you start talking about the price to
live here how people are having to sleep
because they can't afford it
oh yeah these are interesting times at
Oakland and I hope it's somebody
Chronicles or to pay your way in a book
for Marcus Congrats on your book KD
Kevin Durant's relentless pursuit to be
the greatest enjoyed this chat let's do
it again real soon thank you appreciate
it you bet at Thompson scribe on Twitter
and it's his Instagram at Thompson
underscore scribe on Twitter for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app